we now need to let these young people
know that they have been do you know we
we have we have kind of let our guard
down and and this is kind of segue for
that where we let our guard down so it's
probably the most important place we can
think about and saw the educational
system as we've been kind of moving on
and having our big dreams and you're
being your eternal optimist that we are
as a country building our future our
kids and and and vacation we have not
understood that evils been at our
doorstep every single step of the way
they have gotten into our educational
system for decades and they have eaten
away like little termites on the most
important thing that we can we can have
to keep our future and knowledge of our
past what we've done together and most
importantly what makes our country work
the free market we have kids coming out
of college hating our country because of
the about Marxist laboratories if we've
been together for the last few decades
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report reminder everybody to subscribe
to our YouTube channel and click that
pesky notification bell so that you're
alerted when our new videos drop and
joining me today is a former NFL star
and Super Bowl champion now running for
Congress in Utah's fourth district
Burgess Owens welcome to the Rubin
report Dave thanks so much looking
forward to our chat for sure I'm glad to
have you man because you are blowing up
every time I turn on television now I
just did the Greg Gutfeld show with you
a couple days ago but every time I see
somebody talking on Twitter a video of
somebody doing something you're you seem
to be right in the middle of things
you're you're enjoying this little I
really am I really am because you know
we're having a conversation that's been
long overdue day but you know we've been
talking to hypothetically what could
happen with socialism Marxism I mean
this it's a conversation in half four
years and really not get through we have
an opportunity right now to let people
know this is the way it looks when you
give left power they have no clue to
deal with it other than to abuse it so I
think this is obviously it's tough times
but what I've come to understand about
America and I know our history and we go
through the toughest of times and snows
we as long as we know what the endgame
is what it takes to win we've come
together we put aside our differences
for a little bit of time and we go out
there and make things
happen so I see this is a great
opportunity to talk with our Democratic
minutes to love our country to our black
business owners for sure they definitely
get it and then those who have in the
past not been really engaged
we are literally fighting for the
hardest of our nation and those guys on
other side are totally there there
they're going nuts because they realize
how close they are to losing at all so
they are all hands on board and just
know that this will be a probably most
important few months we have coming up
in front of us now we just make sure we
take advantage of it and just and as Oh
Al Davis just to stay in old days just
win baby we need to get that done just
win baby so that's actually partly why I
wanted to have yann because because of
your history as an athlete as an NFL
player and even the way you answered
that question there's there's always a
certain rhythm which I've always loved
the way so many athletes speak about
things and and obviously you have some
of that and and I think we sort of need
a little bit more of that right now
people who know how to win not not win
at all costs but win within a certain
framework of rules and respect for each
other and respect for the country and I
really sense that out of you and I'll
tell you what I'm excited about I've
been hearing from a lot of my peers
though college peers and NFL peers but
when we came to a time when it's quite
different we came to a time where our
parents did such a great job and this is
the thing that I think is being lost we
have had this last generation the great
generation was truly remarkable they
succeeded in so many different ways and
to say that they were half this and
hopeless and oppressed as they is a is a
put-down to them in a big big way but
what I've been getting is calls from our
guys that I came through the college and
pro and they're all on board we'd love
the fact we're now talking about
standing for a flag standing for our
country respect which we were taught by
our parents to do and we now need to let
these young people know that they have
been do you know we we have we have kind
of let our guard down and and this is
kind of segue for that where we let our
guard down so it's probably the most
important place we can think about and
saw the educational system as we've been
kind of moving on and have no big dreams
and you'll be near eternal optimist that
we are as a country building our future
our kids and-and-and vacation we have
not understood that evils been on our
doorstep every single step of the way
they have gotten into our educate
system for decades and they have eaten
away like little termites on the most
important thing the weekend we can have
to keep our future and knowledge of our
past what we've done together and most
importantly what makes our country work
the free market we have kids coming out
of college hating our country because of
the about Marxist laboratories that we
even put together for the last few
decades so so this is a good time for us
even to start addressing that issue one
of the things I cannot wait to do and
we're gonna get the Congress by the way
let me just give you guys a little quick
advertisement Burgess for Utah comm
Burgess for Utah
go there all right I always be I promise
yeah I was gonna do it at the end let's
back up a little bit cuz you hit a
couple turns there so you mentioned the
greatest generation and and you're
talking about how so much of what's
happening now seems to be an erasure of
past so you thought you've had a pretty
amazing pass you were one of the first
three black football players at
University of Miami everybody knows
about the incredible football history
there can you just back up first and
just tell us a little bit about where
you're from what you what your folks
were like just growing up all I love to
I would love to because this is probably
the biggest pride I have is my
upbringing and and because so many
people don't know about it it's a
shocker it's important to realize but
the message of my background my
background is very simply this this
country will give anyone the opportunity
to get to the middle class if we will
understand the tenants that we need to
get there and it doesn't matter how poor
we come what color we are how little we
understand language if we understand
it's all about education faith industry
and family we got it so that being said
my are the black community because they
understood those tenets the 40s 50s and
60s led our country in the growth in
middle class men matriculated with
college men committed to marriage it was
70 percent and in percentage of
entrepreneurs we had now communities
business owners everywhere kids my doing
know white people might in my community
so everything was driven by by black
entrepreneurs that where'd you go
where'd you grow up and tallahassee
tallahassee florida deep south
tallahassee days with KKK Jim Crow
segregation I didn't have my first
interaction with white Americans until I
was 16 years old but I grew up in a
community it was so
who they were how dads came back war
they were proud of who they were I was
taught never let that flag touch the
ground it'll be desecrated it was really
proud of that but the most important
thing is that the 40% of business
ownership equated to over 50 to 60
percent of black Americans across our
country DC that South Texas California
we had relatives all across the board
all part of the middle class and that
was the way our country was our race was
that has been flipped upside down where
we now have 3.8% business ownership and
that's of course our middle class is
going down and unfortunately most
important thing about the middle class
most of it now has become elitist of a
great big group of elitist
a bigger group of poor and a very small
group of that very empathetic loving
serving outside the box thinking
middle-class so we have to get that back
and Dave I'll tell you if I can just
warn our fellow Americans what we're
what the real attack is the real value
we're fighting right now obviously is
our culture but what the left wants to
do is destroy our middle class why
because the middle class is a
stakeholder of our culture that's we
find the best of Americans those who's
going out there they work they pay that
they pay their bills they pay their
payroll they dream they're fill that
stump back up again and their goal is
verson to build something and give to
their kids a legacy and here's other
piece of it
business owners realize one thing when
when customers come through that door
they know what they have a discipline to
be a nice person why cuz they wanted to
come back again even if they're
knuckleheads they want to come back and
keep buying this product that is the
nest inspire other people to our country
the big of that middle class is the more
vibrant our freedom really is and the
more educated we are in the whole bit
and that's what they're after
that's where we look at their Kolbert
what they were trying to do these
Marxist these these folks who are
totally heartless because they've never
understood where there's a build of
business they wanted to shut down our
economy shut down business and make they
make sure they fail why because the end
of the day they want a power in November
they allow these mayors allow these
thugs that come through these these
black communities and every four years
destroy them destroy the infrastructure
why because that those black business
owners will become there lifting
themselves out of that poverty to the
middle class so this is what we're after
if we understand that then we understand
our enemy and enemy it's not us it's not
it's not a Republicans and Democrats
independence is those who truly adhere
to an evil ideology of socialism Marxism
and because they do they can care less
they have no heart for anybody else but
themselves and they don't mind and in my
case with the black community they will
use abuse and discard because that's
what it takes for them to continue to
win their battle as somebody that grew
up in the segregated south Jim Crow laws
and you mentioned you didn't really have
interactions with with white America
let's say till you're 16 years old
you know then you become a NFL star you
playing in college NFL star Super Bowl
champion have done all sorts of other
stuff since then are you shocked that in
2020 right now as we talk that we
seemingly at our are at our what the
media would tell you is our worst race
race relations in decades I don't think
it's actually true I think it's just the
way that it's being framed and pushed on
us but but are you shocked it's sort of
the moment that we're at right now well
I guess I can't say I'm shocked because
I know the the enemy is tenacious they
are they they just don't give up there's
no shame if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell